Headpieces. People wear headpieces
and we saw the pope's hat, and clearly
that was just stolen from the pope,
but you have things like Frances McDormand wore this,
and I don't know how she gets cell reception
with that thing on.
(audience laughs)
It's insane looking.
This was from the Valentino collection,
which literally was a collection
that made me cry it was so beautiful,
and the most exciting part of that
was that she walked up to me while we were waiting
to do the steps, the red carpet, and she was like,
"I love you, you are wonderful."
That's so nice.
And I was like dying, and then she took off the hat,
scratched her head, put it back on, and walked away.
(laughing)
I was like...
(claps erratically)
I was like, "Oh my god! She deserves an Oscar!"
Uh, yeah. Just for that alone.
Just wearing that thing, it must be painful.
It must be awkward, yes.
Speaking of painful, I want you to...
Here you are with SZA, and SZA and I go way back.
And I love me some SZA.
Now there's SZA, and you...
What's happening here? Because you...
So, we took a selfie together,
and I don't know if you can tell,
but that beautiful headpiece she has on
was so sharp on the ends, and in our selfie
she caught on to a tuft of my hair,
and I was like, "Oh god."
So when a photographer came over to take a picture,
I was like, "I'm not falling for that shit again."
And I was like...
You can see in the photo that you're desperately...
And I was like,
"I will not lose an eye, not even for SZA!"
It does like if shit broke out
and a brawl started, SZA could just start
swinging her head around.
Absolutely.
And you could get behind her,
and she would get you through the crowd.
I would get on her back, and we would go.
[Conan] And you would just go.
We would go, yeah.